we have a voicemail number that number
is 2192 David P this caller asks a good
question which is
would Joe Rogan ever have me back on his
show given that I have been critical of
him about this statements about covet
and the pandemic take a listen
hey David uh this is Anthony from New
Jersey I just listened to your uh
podcast today and uh you've played that
clip with Rogan interviewing the guy who
claims he uh invented uh
I'm RNA vaccines
um I was just wondering is there a
chance that you're ever going to go on
Rogan or have Rogan come on your show so
you could just call him out on his
nonsense I mean he just sits there like
like an idiot like a bump on a lot while
these guys just spew out garbage and he
doesn't even do anything
to
you know form a referral it almost seems
like he agrees with it half the time we
need somebody a man of your caliber to
go on there and tell this stoned idiot
you know then he needs to wake up well
listen I don't know that we need the ad
hominems I know that there are other
people in my space who have opted not to
critique the things Joe Rogan has said
and some of them privately will message
me and say that critique you did of Joe
Rogan was really good
um I don't know why that's their choice
I know that to some degree with someone
with such a big show as Rogan you want
to maintain the possibility at least of
being invited on
um it would be very notable if I was not
criticizing the things Rogan was saying
because I'm obviously aware aware of
them I've been on his show a couple of
times as I've said before I have no idea
if Rogan is even aware of the things I
have said about his coverage uh if he is
he may be very willing to talk to me and
we would just have adult conversations
about these things and I would tell them
the same thing to his face that I say on
the show it's not a big deal I'm
comfortable disagreeing with people it's
not it's not a big deal he may be mad in
some way or you know have written me off
or he may have no idea whatsoever I am
glad to go back absolutely anytime uh
okay on the bonus show today I will
explain many of you noticing that I do
have a Band-Aid on my finger uh it is
actually quite a story what happened I
am gonna explain that on today's bonus
show we're going to talk about TED
Cruz's impeachment promise
uh you can probably guess what it is and
we will also talk about
fluorona fluorona has been detected a
combination flu coronavirus diagnosis
all of those stories and more will be on
today's bonus show access the bonus show
by signing up at joinpakman.com you can
use the coupon code wow 22.
you have to say it that way when you
type it in WoW 22 w o w 2 2 you will
save big and we'll see you on today's
bonus show